Mira'nın bahçesinde usta, sabahtan beri bir duvar örüyordu.
Duvar kocamandı ama usta her seferinde tek bir tuğla koyuyordu.
Mira yaklaştı ve elini taze harcın soğukluğuna değdirdi.
Bu duvar, üst üste dizilmiş küçük parçalardan yapılmıştı.
Peki ya biz?
Kedi, papatya, Mira'nın kendisi?
Mira avucuna baktı.
Hiçbir yerinde tuğla göremiyordu.
Ama vardı.
Sadece gözde görülemeyecek kadar küçüktü.
Canlıların en küçük yapı taşının bir adı var.
Hücre.
Mira mutfağa girdi.
Masanın üstünde bir soğan duruyordu.
Soğanı ikiye böldü.
Katmanların arasında ince, ıslak bir zar vardı.
Zar'ı tırnağının ucuyla kaldırdı.
Neredeyse cam kadar saydamdı.
Zar'ı bir cam lamın üstüne yatırdı ve üstünü kapattı.
Mikroskopun lambasını yaktı.
Işık camın altından yukarı vurdu.
Mira gözünü merceğe yasladı ve duvarı yeniden gördü.
Bu sefer soğanın içinde.
Her tuğlanın kendi sınırı vardı.
Buna hücre zar'ı diyoruz.
Zar, hücrenin kapısıdır.
Neyin girip çıkacağını o karar verir.
Zar'ın içi boş değildi.
Jöle gibi berrak bir sıvıyla doluydu.
Bu sıvının adı sitoplazma.
Bütün organeller onun içinde yüzer.
Ortada ışığı içine çeken koyu bir küre duruyordu.
Çekirdek.
Hücrenin yönetim merkezi.
Bütün emirler oradan çıkar.
Mira vida'yı çevirdi ve büyütme bir kat daha arttı.
Sitoplazmanın içinde çalışan minik yapılar belirdi.
Organeller.
İlki fasulye biçimliydi.
İçi kıvrım kıvrım katlanmıştı.
Mitokondri.
Hücrenin enerji santrali.
Koşarken, uyurken hatta şu an bile enerjiyi o üretiyor.
Yanında noktacıklar vardı.
Hepsinden küçüktüler ama sayıları en çoktu.
Libozon.
Büyümemiz için gereken proteinleri üretir.
Onların ardından katlanmış sarlardan bir yol ağa uzanıyordu.
Endoplazmik letikulüm.
Hücrenin içindeki taşıma yolları.
Yolun ucunda üst üste dizilmiş yassı keseler duruyordu.
Golgic isimciyi.
Üretileni paketler ve gideceği yere gönderir.
Bir kese içine aldığı iri parçayı yavaşça eritti.
Lizozon.
Hücrenin temizlikçisi.
Atıkları os indirir.
Kenarda içi sıvı dolu, şeffaf bir kese kabarıyordu.
Koful.
Hücrenin deposu.
Su, besin ve atık orada saklanır.
Zarın hemen altında yeşil, mercek biçimli yapılar sıralanmıştı.
Kloroplast.
Güneş ışığı ile besin üretir.
Yeşil renkte ondan gelir.
Mira başını kaldırdı.
Bu soğandı.
Peki kendisi?
Temiz bir kaşığın ucunu yanağının içine hafifçe sürdü.
Kaşıktakini ikinci bir cam lama aktardı.
Merceğin altında bu sefer hiç kaşe yoktu.
Soğanın hücreleri köşeliydi.
Çünkü dışlarında sert bir hücre duvarı vardı.
Mira'nınkiler yuvarlaktı.
Onlarda hücre duvarı yoktu.
Soğanda yeşil kloroplastlar vardı.
Mira'nın hücresinde hiç yoktu.
Buna karşılık Mira'nınkinde iki minik çubuk vardı.
Sentrozon.
Hücre bölüneceği zaman devreye girer ve çoğalmaya yardım eder.
Soğanda tek büyük koful vardı.
Mira'nınkinde küçük küçük birkaç tane.
Mira gözünü mercekten ayırdı.
Mutfak aynıydı.
Değişen tek şey Mira'nın bakabildiği yerdi.
Bahçeye döndü.
Usta son tuğlayı yerine koymuştu.
Duvarda, soğanda, Mira'da aynı şeyden yapılmıştı.
Küçük parçalardan.
Yani hücrelerden.